حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
‏a quickinder quick please no food or
drinks in the carpet areas only
last night unfortunately we had some
major spills upstairs you know it
happens we can't blame someone for the
spill so that's why we don't want anyone
bringing anything that's not food or
that's not water.
[Silence]
استقيموا واعتدوا استقيموا استقيموا
واستووا صووا الصف سدوا الخلل
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
تبارك الذي بيده الملك وهو على كل شيء
قدير
الذي خلق الموت والحياه ليبلوكم ايكم احسن
عملا وهو العزيز الغفور
الذي خلق لكم الذي خلق سبع سماوات
طباقا
ما ترى في خلق الرحمن من تفاوت فارجع
البصر هل ترى من فطور
ثم ارجع البصر كرتين ينقلب اليك البصر
خاسئا
وهو حسير
ولقد زينا السماء
الدنيا بمصابيح وجعلناها
وجعلناها رجوما للشياطين
واعتدنا لهم عذاب السعير
وللذين كفروا بربهم عذاب جهنم وبئس المصير
اذا القوا فيها سمعوا لها شهيقا
وهي تفور
تكاد تميز من الغيظ
كلما القي فيها فوجهم
خزنتها الم ياتكم نذير
قالوا بلى قد جاؤنا
نذير فكذبنا وقلنا ما نزل الله من شيء ان
انتم الا في ضلال كبير
وقالوا لو كنا نسمع او نعقل ما كنا في
اصحاب السعير
فاعترفوا بذنبهم
فسحقا لاصحاب السعير
ان الذين يخشون ربهم هم بالغيب لهم مغفره
لهم مغفره واجر كريم
لهم مغفره
واجر كبير
واسروا قولكم او اجهروا به انه عليم بذات
الصدور
الا يعلم من خلق هو اللطيف الخبير
هو الذي جعل لكم الارض ذلولا فامشوا في
مناكبها
فامشوا في مناكبها وكلوا من رزقه واليه
النشور
امنتم
من في السماء
ان يخسف بكم الارض فاذا اذا هي تنور
امنتم
من في السماء
ان يرسل عليكم حاصبا
فستعلمون
كيف نذير
ولقد كذب الذين من قبلهم فكيف كان نكير
اولم يروا الى الطير فوقهم صافثات
ويقبضن
ما يمسكهن
الا الرحمن
انه
بكل شيء
بصير
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين ايا اياك
نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
امن هذا الذي هو جند لكم ينصركم
من دون الرحمن
ان الكافرون الا في غرور
امن
هذا الذي يرزقكم ان امسك رزقه
بل لجوا في عتو
ونفور
افمن يمشي مكبا على وجهه اهداه
اهدى من يمشي سويا على صراط مستقيم
قل هو الذي انشاكم
وجعل لكم السمع والابصار والافئده
قليل قليلا
ما تشكرون
قل هو الذي ذراكم في الارض واليه تحشرون
ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم صادقين
قل انما
العلم عند الله
وانما
انا نذير مبين فلم لما راوه زلفه
سيئت
وجوه الذين كفروا
وقيل هذا الذي كنتم
به تدعون
قل ارايتم ان اهلكني الله ومن معي او
رحمنا
فمن يجير الكافرين من عذاب
اليم
قل هو الرحمن امنا
به وعليه توكلنا
فستعلمون
من هو في ضلال مبين
قل ارايتم ان اصبح ماؤكم
غورا
فمن
ياتيكم
النعين
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
سبحان الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏I'm looking for
in
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله اما بعد ان شاء
الله
تراويح
‏and
however
quickly
you think of us
reg
‏timeing
ised up no
you have so muchra time you guys
what abouts man i could do anything
right now i have so much extra time
do not stop coming to
‏If you to even occ that time even alone
at home
in of taking that time to
you know do whatever is that we do and
kind after over
try to time
it in
it in the
‏make
time
and it
comes you can here and you can build on
top of it you can add to it. Don't just
let it go back to waste and go back to
being squandered or lost as it very
usually is.
‏Yah here
another
12 minutes and make
انء الله
make
29th
will
ان شاء الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
‏could any could
be
so much
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
الرحمن
علم القران
خلق الانسان
علمه البيان
صدق الله العظيم اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد
تب القلوب ودعاؤه ونور الابصار ودياؤه
وعافيه الابدان وشفاؤه اللهم ارنا الحق حق
وارزقنا اتباعه وارنا الباطل باطل وارزقنا
اجتنابه اللهم وفقنا لما تحبه وترضاه
ربشرح لي صدري ويسر لي امري واحلل عقده من
لساني يفقه قولي
‏MCC leaders comm
bless
was it to me was
time it I hope that get some if not all
and
‏here
as go takais
and
I one of those children of beauful
community and yesterday
I certainly I wanted to talk a little
bit more about kind of food wastage and
and and and how important that is
particularly in terms of intentionality
[Silence]
‏off first and for to all humility so we
may all benit from it first of all my
and all of انء الله
الرحمن সুان الله
with
us translated the most beneficent or the
most merful but interesting that mercy
is useless if you are powerless
‏some
mery
down mery only down and one the way
in which the quah
ches to personify mercy in the qu is
particularly when h about and when
spashes on ‏that
that earth finds vibrance and life once
again and certainly we all here in the
desert and we all know what dead earth
looks particularly when you see
the gravel and the and the crackling
sand beneath your feet and so it is that
mercy that comes from down from from on
high and one of the beautiful things
about is that it is coupled often
الغز
الرحيم
حالقام
[Silence]
‏and so of
langageان
‏angel
anger
and
becomes really important with that is a
cann beed it is tempar
no matter what it is that particular
state of
‏is no matter how exposive
it is always going to be temporary
because of intensity
and so when
as we mention yesterday الله سبحانه وى
says
الرحمه out of all the way he could have
maned himself to
his creation he chose to do it through
the lens of
‏in love and care and compassion and all
this mercy
and as a pediatrician not to reflect
upon when we hear how
the etology of com so close to the wom
of the mother it's interesting that the
mother particularly as soon as she finds
out that she's pregnant she is madly in
love with that child she is madly
[Silence]
ஹ
الله
سبحان الله
the
compassion that envelop it
does thatind us of anything
that notind us of ours
does that notind us of
الله سبحانه وتالى
حال
مقام مقام
الرحيم
سبحان الله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الله
سبحانه وتعالى
حالقام
‏in
tempy
with
las existation
when the falls it does not to fall only
upon the musl it does not only fall upon
the
vibrantows but it also falls upon the
dirt it also falls upon the earth
‏could
mery
and asle
this
man
القران خلق الانسان علمه البيان
‏engage
make anyah
the
infinate
anding
the
teach it
اللهent
‏entes
الله سبحانه وتالى
and خلق الانسان
علم
خلق
علرate
and
the mankind
and then he that mankind eloquence and
the ability to be able to formulate
thoughts and consciousness
‏If you look at the act chronological
order would made much more that the most
loving first created the man
he that manoqu and finally after he
then he him the manation of the qu the
way how to evencri the quران
we talked about last time شهر رمضان
انزل القران للناس
والبينات
من الهدى والفرقان
[Silence]
زر
‏Bast
to
as com
الرحمن الرحم علم القران خلق الانسان
manif
الله سبحانه وتالى
سبحان الله
was before man was
inر الله سبحانه وتالى
man and الا ليعبون
othercept
that you do not know how can you worship
that which you have not surrendered
yourself in humility to
so the purpose
رش
اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور
الرحيم
الله سبحانه وتالى
جزاك
[Silence]
علي
الله
[Silence]
شيخ علي
شويه
اه
[Silence]
استقيموا واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصب الخلل
كلوز جاب ستريت
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم نون
والقلم وما يسترون
ما انت بنعمه ربك بمجنون
وان لك لاجر غير ممنون
وانك
لعلى خلق عظيم فستبصر ويبصرون
بايكم المفتون
ان ربك هو اعلم بمن ضل عن سبيله وهو اعلم
بالمهتدين ين فلا تطع المكذبين
ودوا لو تدهن فيدهنون
ولا تطع كل حلاف مهين
مناع للخير معتد اثيم
هماز
مشاء
بنميم
من ناعم للخير معتد اثيم عت
بعد ذلك زم
كان ذا مال
وبنين
اذا تتلى عليه اياتنا قال اساطير الاولين
سنسمه
على الخرطوم
بلوناهم كما بلونا اصحاب الجنه
اذ اقسموا ليصرنها
مصبحين
ولا يستثنون
فطاف عليها طائف
من ربك وهم مئون
فاصبحت كالصريم
فتنادوا مصبحين
ان اغدوا على حرفكم ان كنتم صارين
فانطلقوا
وهم يتخافتون
الا يدخلنها
اليوم عليكم مسكين
وغدوا على حرد قادرين
فلما راوها قالوا
انا لضالون
بل نحن محرومون
قال اوسطهم الم قال اوسطهم الم اقل لكم
لولا تسبحون
قالوا سبحان ربنا انا كنا ظالمين
فاقبل بعضهم
على بعض يتلاون
قالوا يا ويلنا انا كنا طاغين
عسى ربنا ان يبدلنا خيرا منها انا الى
ربنا راغبون
كذلك العذاب
ولعذاب الاخره اكبر لو كانوا يعلمون
ان للمتقين عند ربهم جنات
النعيم افنجعل المسلمين كالمجرمين
ما لكم كيف تحكمون
ام لكم كتاب فيه تدرسون
ان لكم فيه لما تخيرون
ام لكم ايمان علينا بالغه الى يوم القيامه
ان
لكم لما تحكمون
سلهم ايهم
بذلك زعيم
ام لهم شركاء
فلياتوا بشركائهم
ان كانوا صادقين
يوم يدعون الى يوم يكشف عن ساق
ويدعون الى السجود فلا يستطيعون
خاشعه ابصارهم ترهقهم ذله وقد كانوا يدعون
الى السجود وهم سالمون
فذرني ومن يكذب بهذا الحديث سنستدر رجهم
من حيث لا يعلمون
واملي لهم ان كيدي متين
ام تسالهم اجرا فهم
من مغرم مثقلون
ام عندهم
الغيب فهم يكتبون
فاصبر لحكم ربك ولا تكن كصاحب الحوت اذ اذ
نادى وهو مكذوم
لولا ان تداركه نعمه من ربه لنبذ بالعراء
لنبذ بالعراء
وهو مذموم
فاجتباه ربه فجعله من الصالحين
وان كاد وان يك ان كاد الذين كفروا
ليزلقونك
بابصارهم
لما سمعوا الذكر
وان يكادوا الذين كفروا ليزلقونك
بابصارهم
لما سمعوا الذكر ويقولون انه
لمجنون
وما هو الا ذكر للعالمين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
الحاقه
وما ادراكما الحاقه
كذبت ثمود وعاد بالقارعه
فاما اما ثمود فاهلكوا بالطاغيه
واما عاد فاهلكوا بريح صرصر عاتيه
سخرها عليهم سبع ليال وثمانيه ايام حسوما
فترى القوم فيها صرعا كانهم
اعجاز نخل خاويه
فهل ترم
باقيه
وجاء فرعون ومن قبله والمؤتفكات
بالخطئه
فعصوا رسول ربهم فاخذهم اخذه رابيه
انا لما
طغى الماء
حملناكم في الجار يه
لنجعلها لكم تذكره
وتعيها اذن واعيه
فاذا نفخ في الصور نفخه واحده وحملت الارض
والجبال فدكتا دكه
واحده
فيومئذ
وقعت الواقعه
وانشقت
السماء
فهي يومئذ
واهيه
والملك على ارجائها
ويحمل عرش ربك فوقهم يومئذ
ثمانيه
يومئذ
تعرضون لا تخفى منكم خافيه
فاما
من اوتي كتابه
بعونه
فيقول
فيقول ها
اقراوا كتابيه
اني ظننت
اني ملاقي الحسابيه
فهو في عيشه راضيه
في جنه
عاليه
قطوفها دانيه
كلوا واشربوا هنيئا
بما اسلفتم في الايام الخاليه
واما من اوتي كتابه بشماله
فيقول
فيقول يا ليتني لم اوت كتابيه
ولم ادري ما حسابيه
يا يتها كانت القاضيه
من
اغنى عني ماليه
هلك عني
سلطانيه
خذوه فظلوه
ثم الجحيم صلوه
ثم في سلسله
زرعها سبعون ذراعا
فاسلكوه
انه
كان لا يؤمن بالله العظيم
ولا يحض على طعام المسكين
فليس له اليوم هاه حميم ولا طعام الا من
غسلين
لا ياكله
الا الخاطئون
فلا اقسم بما تبصرون وما لا تبصرون
انه لقول رسول كريم
وما هو بقول شاعر
قليلا ما تؤمنون
ولا بقول كاهن قليلا ما تذكرون
تنزيل
من رب العالمين
ولو تقول علينا بعض الاقاويل
لاخذنا منه بالوتين ثم لقطعناه
لاخذنا منه به يمين
ثم
لاقطعنا منه الوتين
فما منكم من احد عنه حاجزين
وانه
لتذكره للمتقين
واننا
لنعلم ان منكم مكذبين
وانه
لحسره على الكافرين
لحق اليقين
فسبح باسم ربك العظيم
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط راط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
سال سائل
بعذاب واقع للكافرين
ليس له دافع من الله ذي المعارج ج
تعرج الملائكه
والروح اليه في يوم كان مقداره 50 ال سنه
فاصبر صبرا جميلا
انهم يرونه بعيدا
ونراه قريبا
يوم تكون السماء
كالمهل وتكون الجبال بال كالعهن ولا يسال
حميم حميما
يبصرونهم
يود المجرم لو يفتدي من عذاب يومئذ
ببنيه
وصاحبته
واخيه
وفصيلته التي تؤويه
ومن في الارض جميعا ثم ينجي
كلا انها
لظاه
للشوى
تدعو من ادبر وتولى ف تدعوا من ادبر وتولى
تدعو من ادبر وتولى وجمع فاوعا
ان
الانسان
خلق هلوعا
اذا مسه الشر جزوعا
واذا مسه الخير منوعا الا المصلين
الا المصلين الذين هم على صلاتهم دائمون
والذين في اموالهم حق
معلوم
السائل
والمحروم
والذين يصدقون بيوم الدين
والذين هم من عذاب ربهم مشفقون
ان عذاب ربهم غير مامون
والذين هم لفروجهم حافظون
الا على ازواجه
او ما ملكت ايمانهم فانهم غير ملوين
فمن ابتغى وراء ذلك فاولئك
هم العادون
والذين هم لاماناتهم
وعهدهم راعون
والذين هم
بشهاداتهم
قائمون
والذين هم على صلاتهم يحافظون
اولئك
في جنات
مكرمون
فما للذين كفروا قبلك مهطعين
عن اليمين وعن الشمال عزين
ايطنع كل امر
منهم ان يدخل جنه نعيم
كلا
انا خلقناهم
مما يعلمون
فلا اقسم برب المشارق والمغارب انا
لقادرون
على ان نبدل خيرا منهم وما نحن بمسبوقين
فذرهم يخوضوا ويلعبوا حتى يلاقوا يومهم
الذي يوعدون
يوم يخرجون من الاجداث سراعا كانهم
الى نصب ينفضون
خاشعه ابصارهم
ترهقهم ذله
ذلك اليوم الذي كانوا يوعدون
[Arabic recitation]
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
انا ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه اني لكم نذير
مبين
انا ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه ان انذر قومك
انذر قومك من قبل ان ياتيهم عذاب اليم
قال يا قوم اني لكم نذير مبين ان اعبدوا
الله واتقوه واطيعون
يغفر لكم من ذنوبكم ويؤخركم
الى اجل مسمى
ان اجل الى الله اذا جاء لا يؤخر لو كنتم
تعلمون
قال رب اني دعوت قومي ليلا ونهارا
فلم يزدهم دعائي
الا فرارا
وان كلما دعوتهم لتغفر لهم جعلوا جعلوا
اصابعهم في اذانهم واستغشوا ثيابهم
واستغشوا ثيابهم واصروا واستكبروا
استكبارا
ثم اني دعوتهم جهارا
ثم اني اعلنت لهم واسررت لهم اسرارا
فقلت استغفروا ربكم انه كان غفارا
يرسل السماء
عليكم مدرارا
ويمددكم
باموال
وبنين
ويجعل لكم جنات
ويجعل لكم انهارا
ما لكم لا ترجون لله وقارا
لقد خلقكم اطوارا
الم تروا كيف خلق الله سبع سماوات
طباقا
وجعل الشم وجعل القمر فيهن نورا
وجعل الشمس سراجا
والله انبتكم
من الارض نباتا
ثم يعيدكم فيها ويخرجكم
اخراجا
والله جعل لكم الارض بساطا
لتسلكوا منها سبلا فجا
قال نوح رب انهم عصوني واتبعوا من لم يزده
ماله واتبعوا من لم يزده ماله وولده الا
خسارا
مكروا مكرا كبارا
وقالوا لا تذروا الهتكم
ولا تذرن مودا ولا سواعا ولا يغوث ويعوق
ونسرا
وقد اضلوا كثيرا
ولا تزد الظالمين
الا ضلا
مما
خطيئاتهم
اغرقوا فادخلوا نارا
فلم يجدوا لهم من دون الله انصارا
وقال نوح رب لا تذر على الارض من الكافرين
ديارا
انك
ان تذر م يضلوا عبادك
يضلوا عبادك ولا يلدوا الا فاجرا كفارا
رب اغفر لي ولوالدي ولمن دخل بيتي مؤمنا
رب اغفر لي ولوالدي
ولمن دخل بيتي مؤمنا وللمؤمنين
والمؤمنات
ولا تزد الظالمين
الا تبارا
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
بسم
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
موجود
ز
انت يا مولانا
[Silence]
الشيخ
‏Never my whole time.
‏Just a quick
[Silence]
‏I drank my
drank اه
يالام
[Silence]
يس
ما شاء
[Silence]
الج
السلام عليكم ‏Before we start back
for the second half of the
I just wanted to go ahead and announce
the Quran competition winners for
Ramadan Quran competition and also
announce something else. if we could
if we quiet down a little bit just
listen in
there are QR codes put up around the
message on the wall this one here
next to me. ‏QR code you with your and
you
requ
to WhatsApp and myself
will approve it and you be in the group
that way you can get all the latestil
and whatever going on even
time changes and always look to that any
last minut
‏things happn
up to date latn
on
my number on you me priv
anything you get me
let me
compers
for
we have first place is
نمسر
محمد ما شاء الله سوره الروم
ماء الله
ان شاء الله
القمر
قصي ابو ابو عوض
ابو عواد
حماد محمد
عمر سحتوت ما شاء الله سوره الانسان
داليا سحتوت
حسن
first place here we have little
dash you and third place is
so tribe is taking over the seems like
so
we ‏give out the presid
that already got requ
them and you will be part of the club
you be insider
just don't leak our chats to tm
all right
so again the qr codes around the
you zap
ان شاء الله
[Silence]
استووا واعتدلوا
الله
اكبر سبحانك الله وبحمدك
بسم الله
لا اله الا الله اعوذ بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال الين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
قل اوحي الي انه استمع نفر من الجن فقالوا
انا سمعنا
فقالوا انا سمعنا قرانا عجبا
يهدي الى الرشد فامنا
به ولن نشرك بربنا احدا
وانه
تعالى جد ربنا ما اتخذ صاحبه
ولا ولدا
وانه كان يقول سفيهنا على الله شططا
انا ظننا
ان لن تقول الانس والجن على الله كذبا
وانه كان رجال من الانس يعوذون برجال من
الجن
فزادوهم
رهقا
وانهم ظنوا كما ظننتم
ان لن يبع بعث الله احدا
وانا لمسنا السماء
فوجدناها
ملئت حرسا شديدا وشهبا
وانا كنا نقعد منها مقاعد للسمع فمن يستمع
الان يجد له شهابا رصدا
وانا لا ندري اشر اريد بمن في الارض ام
اراد بهم ربهم رشدا
وانا منا الصالحون ومنا دون ذلك كنا طرائق
قددا
وانا ظننا
ان لن نعجز الله في ارض ولن نعجزه هربا
وانا لماما سمعنا سمعنا الهدى امنا
به فمن يؤمن بربه فلا يخاف بخسا
ولا رهقا
وانا منا المسلمون ومنا القاس سطون
فمن اسلم فاولئك
تحروا رشدا
واما القاسطون فكانوا لجهنم
حطبا
وان لو استقاموا على الطريقه لاسقيناهم
ماء
غدقا لنفتنهم فيه
ومن يعرف رض عن ذكر ربه يسلكه عذابا
صعدا
وان المساجد لله فلا تدعوا مع الله احدا
وانه لما قام عبد الله يدعوه كادوا يكونون
عليه لبدا
قل انما ادع ربي ولا اشرك به احدا
قل اني لا املك لكم ضرا ولا رشدا
قل اني لن يجيرني من الله احد ولن اجد من
دونه ملتحدا
الا بلاغا من الله ورسالاته
من يعصي الله ورسوله فان له نار جهنم
خالدين فيها
ابدا
حتى اذا راوا ما يوعدون فسيعلمون
من اضعف ناصرا
واقل عددا
قل ان ادري اقريب
ما توعدون ام يجعل له ربي امدا
عالم الغيب فلا يظهر على غيبه
احدا
الا من ارتضى من رسول فانه يسلك من بين
يديه ومن خلفه رصدا
ليعلم ان قد ابلغوا رسالات ربهم واحاط
احاط بما لديهم
واحاط بما لديهم واحصى كل شيء عددا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
يا ايها المزمل
قم الليل الا قليلا
نصفه او انقص منه قليلا
او زد عليه ورت رتل القران ترتيلا
انا سنلقي عليك قولا ثقيلا
ان ناشئه الليل هي اشد وطءا
واقوم مقيلا
ان لك في النهار سبحا طويلا
واذكر اسم ربك وتبتل اليه تبت تلا
رب المشرق والمغرب
اله الا هو فاتخذه وكيلا
واصبر على ما يقولون واهجرهم هجرا جميلا
وذرني والمكذبين
اولي النعمه ومهلهم قليلا
ان لدينا نا انكالا
وجحيما
وطعاما
ذا غصه
وعذابا اليما
يوم
ترجف الارض والجبال وكانت الجبال كثيبا
مهيلا
انا
ارسلنا اليكم رسولا شاهدا دا عليكم كما
ارسلنا الى فرعون رسولا
فعصى فرعون الرسول فاخذناه اخذا
وبيلا
فكيف تتقون
فكيف تتقون ان كفرتم يوما يجعل الولدان
شيبا
السماء ماء
منفطر
به كان وعده مفعولا
ان هذه تذكره
فمن شاء
اتخذ الى ربه سبيلا
ان ربك يعلم انك تقوم ادنى من ثلثي الليل
ونصفه وثلثه
وطائفه
من الذين معك والله يقدر الليل والنهار
علم ان لن تحصوه فتاب عليكم
فاقراوا ما تيسر من القران
علم
سيكون منكم مرضى واخرون يضربون في الارض
يضربون في الارض يبتغون من فضل الله
واخرون
واخرون يجاهدون في سبيل الله
يق واخرون يقاتلون في سبيل الله
فاقراوا ما تيسر منه واقيموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه واقرضوا الله قرضا حسنا
وما تقدموا لانفسكم
من خير تجدوه عند الله
تجدوه عند الله هو ا هو اعظ
تجدوه عند الله
هو خير
هو خيرا واعظم اجرا
واستغفر الله
ان الله غفور رحيم
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
سبحان رب الله
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
يا
ايها المدثر
قم فانذر
وربك فكبر
وثيابك فطهر
والرجز فاهجر ولا تمنن تستكثر
ولربك فاصبر
فاذا نقر في
الناقور
فذلك يومئذ يوم عسير
على الكافرين غير يسير
ذرني ومن خلقت وحيدا
وجعلت له مالا ممدودا
وبنين شهودا
ومهدت له تمهيدا
ثم يطمع ان ازيد
كلا انه كان لاياتنا
عنيدا
سارهقه صعودا
انه فكر وقدر فقتل كيف قدر ثم قتل كيف قدر
ثم نظر ثم عبس وبس ثم ادبر واستكبر
فقال ان هذا الا سحر يؤثر ان هذا الا قول
البشر ساصليه سقر وما
ادراكما سقر
لا تبقي ولا تذر
لواحه للبشر
عليها تسعه عشر
وما جعلنا اصحاب النار الا ملائكه
وما جعلنا عدتهم الا فتنه للذين كفروا
ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب ويزداد د
الذين امنوا
ايمانا
ولا يرتاب الذين اوتوا الكتاب والمؤمنون
وليقول الذين في قلوبهم
مرض والكافرون
ماذا
اراد الله بهذا مثلا
كذلك يضل الله من يشاء شاء ويهدي من يشاء
وما يعلم جنود ربك الا هو وما هي الا ذكرى
للبشر
كلا والقمر والليل اذ ادبر والصبح اذا
اسفر انها
لاحدى الكبر نذيرا للبشر شر لمن شاء
يتقدم او يتاخر
كل نفس بما كسبت رهينه
الا اصحاب اليمين
في جنات
يتساءلون
عن المجرمين
ما سل لككم في سقر قالوا لم نكن من
المصلين
ولم نكن نطعم المسكين
وكنا نخوض مع الخائضين
وكنا نكذب بيوم الدين
حتى
اتانا اليقين
فما تنفعهم
شفاعه
الشافعين
فما لهم عن التذكره معرضين
معرضين كانهم
حمر مستنفره
فرت من قسوره بل يريد كل امرئ منهم ان
يؤتى صحفا منشره
كلا ان كلا بل يخافون الاخره
كلا انه
تذكره
فمن شاء
ذكره
وما يذكرون الا ان يشاء الله
هو اهل التقوى واهل المغفره
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
سبحان رب سبحان رب
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
لا
اقسم بيوم القيامه
ولا
اقسم بالنفس اللوامه
ايحسب الانسان
ان لن نجمع عظاما
بلى قادرين على ان نسوي بنانا
بل يريد الانسان ليفجر امامه يسال ايان
يوم القيامه
فاذا برق البصر وخسف القمر وجمع الشمس
والقمر
يقول الانسان
يومئذ اين المفر كلا
وزر الى ربك يومئذ المستقر ينبا الانسان
يومئذ
بما قدم واخر بل الانسان
على نفسه بصيره
ولو القى معاذيره
لا تحرك به لسانك لتعجل به ان علينا جمعه
وقرانه
فاذا قراناه فاتبع قرانا
ثم ان
علينا بيانا
كلا بل تحبون العاجله
وتذرون الاخره
وجوه
يومئذ
ناظره
ناظره الى ربها ناظره
ووجوه
يومئذ
باسره
تظن ان يفعل بها فاقرا
كلا
اذا بلغت التراقي
وقيل من راق
وظن انه الفراق
والتفت الساق بالساق
الى ربك يومئذ المساق
فلا صدق ولا صلى
ولكن كذب وتولى
ثم ذهب الى
اهله يتمطى
اولى لك فاولى ثم
اولى لك فاولى
ايحسب
الانسان
ان يترك سدى
الم يك نطفه من مني يمنى ثم كان علقه فخلق
فسوى
فجعل منه الزوجين الذكر والانثى
اليس ذلك بقادر على ان يحيي الموتى
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
هل اتى على الانسان حين من الدهر لم يكن
شيئا مذكورا
انا خلقنا الانسان من نطفه امشاج نبتليه
نبتليه فجعلناه سميعا بصير بصيرا
انا هديناه السبيل اما شاكرا واما كثورا
انا
اعتدنا للكافرين
سلاسل واغلا
وسعيرا
ان الابرار يشربون من كاس كان مزاجها
كافورا
عين
يشرب بها عباد الله يفجرونها
تفجيرا
يوفون بالنذر ويخافون يوما كان شره
مستطيرا
ويطعمون الطعام على حبه مسكينا
ويتيما
واسيرا
انما نطعمكم
لوجه الله
لا نريد منكم جزاء
ولا شكورا
انا نخاف من ربنا يوما عبوسا قمطريرا
فوقاهم الله شر ذلك اليوم
ولقاهم نظره
وسرورا
وجزاهم
بما صبروا جنه
وحريرا
متكئين فيها على الارائك
لا يرون فيها شمسا ولا زمهريرا
ودانيه عليهم ظلالها وذللت قطوفها تذليلا
ويطاف عليهم بانيه
من فضه
بانيه
من فضه واكواب
كانت قواريرا
قوارير من فضه
قدروها
تقديرا
ويسقون فيها كاسا كان مزاجها زنجبيلا
عينا فيها تسمى
سلسبيلا
ويطوف عليهم ولدان مخلدون
ولدان مخلدون
اذا رايتهم حسبتهم لؤلؤا منثورا
واذا رايت الثم رايت نعيما وملكا كبيرا
عاليهم ثياب سندس خضر واستبرق
وحلوا
اساور من فضه وسقاهم ربهم شرابا طهورا
ان هذا كان لكم جزاء
وكان سعيكم مشكورا
انا نحن نزلنا عليك القران تنزيلا
فاصبر لحكم ربك ولا تطع منهم اثما او
كفورا
واذكر اسم ربك بكره
واصيلا
ومن الليل فاسجد له وسبحه ليلا
طويلا
ان هؤلاء
يحبون العاجله
ويذرون وراءهم
يوما ثقيلا
نحن خلقناهم
وشددنا
اسرهم واذا شئنا بدلنا امثالهم
تبديلا
ان هذه تذكره
فمن شاء اتخذ خذ الى ربه سبيلا
وما تشاؤون
الا ان يشاء
الله
ان الله كان عليما حكيما
يدخل من يشاء
في رحمته
والظالمين
اعد لهم عذابا
اليما
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
سبحان
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والمرسلات عرفا
فالعاصفات عصفا
والناشرات
نشرا فالفارقات
فرقا
فالملقيات ذكرا عذرا او نذرا
انما
توعد عدون لواقع
فاذا النجوم طمست
واذا السماء
فرجت
واذا الجبال نسفت
واذا الرسل اقتت لاي يوم اجلت ليوم الفصل
وما
ادراكما
يوم الفصل ويل يومئذ
للمكذبين
الم نهلك الاولين
ثم نتبعهم الاخرين
كذلك نفعل بالمجرمين
ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
الم نخلقكم
من ماء
مهي
فجعلناه في قرار مكين الى قدر معلوم
فقدرنا فنعم القادرون
ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
الم نجاعل الارض كفاتا
احياء
وامواتا
وجعلنا فيها رواسي شامخات
واسقيناكم
ماء
فرات
ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
انطلقوا
الى ما كنتم به تكذبون
الى ظل ذي ثلاث شعب لا ظليل ولا يغني من
اللهب
انها
ترمي بشرر
كالقصر كانه
جماله
صفر ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
هذا
لا ينطقون
ولا يؤذن لهم فيعتذرون
ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
هذا يوم الفصل جمعناكم والاولين
فان كان لكم كيد فكيدون
ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
ان المتقين في ظلال
وعيون
وفواكه مما
يشتهون
كلوا واشربوا هنيئا
بما كنتم تعملون
انا كذلك نجزي المحسنين
ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
كلوا وتمتعوا قليلا انكم
مجرمون
ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
واذا قيل لهم اركعوا لا يركعون
فباي حديث
بعده يؤمنون
الله
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
سبحان رب
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
زلزالها
واخرجت الارض اثقالها
وقال الانسان
ما لها يومئذ
تحدث اخبارها
بان ربك اوحى
يومئذ
يصدر الناس اشتاتا ليروا اعمالهم
فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا يره ومن يعمل
مثقال ذره
شر
يره
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر سبحان
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
الذي جمع مالا
وعددا
يحسب ان ماله
اخلداه كلا ليبذن
في الحطمه
وما
ادراكما الحطمه
نار الله الموقده
التي تطلع على الافئده
انها
عليهم
مؤصدا
في عمد
ممددا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن من حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين
بسم الله
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم قل اعوذ برب الفلق من شر ما خلق
ومن شر غاسق اذا وقب ومن شر النفاثات
في العقد ومن شر حاسد اذا حسد
[Arabic recitation]
الناس
ملك الناس اله
من شر الوسواس الخناس
الذي يوسوس في صدور الناس
من الجنه
والناس
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه انه لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
اللهم لك الحمد حتى ترضى ولك الحمد اذا
رضيت ولك الحمد بعد الرضا رضا ولك الحمد
على كل حال
لك الحمد انت نور السماوات والارض لك
الحمد انت قيوم السماوات والارض رحمن
الدنيا والاخره ورحيمهما
اللهم صل على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
كما صليت على ال ابراهيم
وبارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما باركت
على ال ابراهيم
انك حميد
مجيد
اللهم اننا عبدك بنو عبدك بنو
امائك نواصينا في يد
ماض فينا حكمك عدل فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل
اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك او انزلته
في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او
استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك
ان تجعل قران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منه ما جهلنا
وذكرنا منه ما نسينا
اللهم علمنا الحكمه منه ربنا اجعل القران
ربيع مع قلوبنا
وحجه لنا وشافعا مشفعا فينا يوم نلقاك
ولا تجعل القران حجه علينا اجعله لنا
دليلا ونورا
في الدنيا والاخره
عند الممات وعند البعث وعلى الصراط نورا
بين ايدينا وبايماننا
ربنا اننا نرجوك
نتبتل اليك
ونتوسل اليك
اللهم اسقل به قلوبنا
وطهر به افئدتنا
وحرق به شياطيننا
وارحمنا به اللهم اجعله رحمه لنا
وانثا
وطمئنين
واجعل قلوبنا وافئدتنا
تطمئن
اليه يا ربنا
اللهم لا انس الا انسك
انسنا
اللهم لا سلوى ولا سكينه الا سلواك
وسكينتك
اللهم سلنا
وانزل السكينه علينا
اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من جهد البلاء
ودرك الشقاء
وسوء القضاء
وشماته الاعداء
اللهم
اننا نسال
عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء
ومرافقه
الانبياء
والنصر على الاعداء
يا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء
يا حيي يا كريم
يا حي يا كريم
يا من يستحيي من عبده اذا ما رفع اليك
كفيه ان تردهما
ان تردهما خائبتين
صفرا ها نحن نرفع اليك كفنا
ونوجه اليك قلوبنا ووجوهنا
اللهم اننا نتوسل اليك
ونتبتل اليك
لما غفرت لنا اللهم اننا نعوذ بك ان نشرك
بك شيئا
نعوذ بك ان نشرك بك شيئا ونحن نعلم
ونستغفرك مما لا نعلم اللهم اننا نسالك
فعل الخيرات
وترك المنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا
واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير
مفتونين
ربنا احينا
ما كانت الحياه خيرا لنا وتوفنا اذا كانت
الوفاه خيرا لنا اللهم اننا نرجوك عزائم
مغفرتك
وموجبات رحمتك والغنيمه من كل بر والفوز
بالجنه
والفوز بالجنه
السلامه من كل اثم والنجاه
من النار
ربنا اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا
من النار
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واخذل الشرك والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المضطه المجاهدين في
غزه وفلسطين
وفي السودان وفي كشمير
وحيث حلوا ربنا انصرهم نصرا مؤزرا
اللهم اجعلهم على عدوهم ظاهرين
عالين
يا رب العالمين
اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين
انه قد عاث في الارض فسادا
وانت لا تحب المفسدين
اللهم انهم ظلموا وسفكوا دماء اوليائك
وسفكوا دماء اهل اله الا اللهم
فانتقم
اللهم اننا نجعلك في نحورهم
ونعوذ بك من شرورهم
اقذف في قلوبهم الهلع والفزع يا رب
العالمين
والذله والصغار حيث كانوا في ارضك اللهم
اننا نرجوك ان تزلزل زل اركانهم
وان تصدع بنيانهم
وان تقتل اجنادهم
واجعل قتلاهم في النيران
واجعل احيائهم في ذل وهوان
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله
رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
سبحان رب
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس
سبحان
ابو موسى الاشعري
رضي الله عنه
صحيح الامام مسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
اذا مرض العبد او سافر كتب له ما كان يعمل
صحيحا مقيما
inidency
ofidalyناه
اسفل سافلين الا الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات
فلهم اجر غير
ممنون ودز ممنون مين
مستمر لا ينقطع
ممنون
دكتور عاصم
شيخاري
من الله
[Silence]
يخ
‏Pur
har
to
each other this is so
other
‏someone
care
ان شاء الله
جزاكم
[Silence]
الف لاباس عليك يا دكتور في السلامه